gerade ist in kuba ein kleiner meteorit
niedergegangen und es scheint
tatsächlich so zu sein dass die
einschläge sogar von größeren asteroiden
zugenommen haben das leben auf der erde
ist in der jüngeren phase der
erdgeschichte deutlich risikoreicher
geworden
ein forschungsteam aus kanada hat
nämlich jetzt herausgefunden dass das
kosmische bombardement auf der erde
angestiegen ist klicks um
science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nicht herzlich willkommen
das asteroiden auf die erde treffen das
ist nichts neues unser planet wurde seit
seiner entstehung ständig von asteroiden
getroffen und das wird wohl auch in
zukunft wieder passieren wir berichten
regelmäßig über dieses thema denn ihr
müsst alle hast du eben einschläge sind
eine reale bedrohung für das leben auf
der erde
im worst case können sie ein
massensterben verursachten bisher gingen
fachleute davon aus dass die einschlags
rate im laufe der erdgeschichte
nach einem anfänglichen intensiven
kosmische bombardement auf einem
niedrigen niveau stabil gewesen ist weil
diese art von forschung und der
ermittlung der einschlags rate gibt es
jedoch eine große herausforderung und
zwar sind auf unserem planeten nur
wenige alte karte erhalten auf dem mond
gibt es eine andere herausforderung hier
sind die entsprechenden krater zwar noch
erhalten und auch gut konserviert
dennoch gestaltete sich die bestimmung
ihres alters bislang als äußerst
kompliziertes unterfangen doch ein
forschungsteam aus dem kanadischen
toronto war jetzt erfolgreich ihnen
gelang es insgesamt 111 krater des
mondes kartieren
als hilfsmittel nutzen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dabei dass die wir je instrument der
nasa sonde lunar reconnaissance orbiter
lro damit ist es möglich die temperatur
der mondoberfläche zu kartographieren
und genau das machte sich das
forschungsteam zunutze sie analysierten
wie viel wärme die krater nachts
abstrahlen und konnten so indirekt das
alter der krater und somit auch die
einschlags rate bestimmen
der trick dabei die brocken auf dem mond
zerfallen im laufe der zeit durch zwei
faktoren zum einen durch sehr viele mini
einschläge und zum anderen durch die
großen temperaturschwankungen zwischen
tag und nacht dabei können kleinere
brocken deutlich weniger
wärme speichern als die größeren
exemplare die wärmeabstrahlung der
krater gibt somit also aufschluss über
das jeweilige alter
die ergebnisse überraschen sogar die
fachleute selbst denn die impact rate
die impact rate des mondes ist demnach
keineswegs stabil gewesen wie bislang
angenommen
stattdessen ist die einschlags rate von
rund 290 millionen jahren auffallend
angestiegen dieser sprung in der kurve
lässt sich laute autorinnen und autoren
auch auf die einschlags rate von
asteroiden auf die erde übertragen
diese annahme konnte das kanadische
forschungsteam auch belegen und zwar
durch die untersuchung von irdischen
krater konkret analysierten sie
sogenanntes kinderlied vorkommen damit
ist ein gestein gemeint dass bei
urzeitlichen vulkanausbrüchen entstanden
ist und das krad besonders gut
konservieren auch hier zeigte sich bei
untersuchungen dass es einen plötzlichen
anstieg des kosmischen bombardements ab
der zeit vor 290 millionen jahren gab
der faktor der impact rate in den
letzten 2 190 millionen jahren ist somit
um 2,6 höher als in der zeit davor dazu
die wissenschaftlerinnen sarah natur
die an der studie beteiligt war unsere
studie liefert belege für eine
dramatische veränderung in der rate der
beiden anschläge auf mond und erde die
sich etwa gegen ende des altertums
ereignete an dieses ergebnis schließt
sich eine super spannende frage an auf
dies bislang aber noch keine gesicherte
antwort gibt was genau führte zu dem
plötzlichen anstieg des bombers
fachleute vermuten dass es an trümmern
liegt die durch eine gewaltige kollision
im asteroidengürtel zwischen jupiter und
mars entstanden sind und noch bis heute
ins innere sonnensystem katapultiert
werden sehr sehr spannend was ist da
passiert damals wir bleiben an dieser
story dran und halten euch auf dem
laufenden
8 mining also bergbau auf aktion könnte
die gefahr eines einschlags von
asteroiden auf der erde noch weiter
erhöhen alles dazu in diesem video auf
jeden fall drauf klicken
achso ihnen bedrohen die erde nach ascot
mining ansonsten bis dann bleib dran